[Musique]
on pique tu sais je me sens fatigué et
en faisant repose
mais toi tu es tout avis pour la
compagnie écrire la suite de cette
légende où tout recommence
oriane sa chair je suis prêt grand-père
dimanche et qu'il faut faire
en place suffit aux ablutions à
l'opération jouons appelle la c zéro
la scène c'est encore hélas mc
d'initiation ont consisté prêt au bras
m
soir de répétition une grande partie des
bénévoles sont là aucun ne voudrait
doubler et maman d'incarnation déroule
car ils jouent plusieurs personnages
dans une dizaine de tableaux
et le jazz o et la metteuse en scène du
spectacle
l'enjeu de la mise en scène c'est que ce
soit harmonieux harmonieux mais à la
seconde près c'est à dire que le but est
que chacun sache ce qu'il a à faire et
on parle de 3 400 personnes pour savoir
ça il faut comprendre l'intention que
l'on cherche à avoir sur scène et c'est
pour ça que je peux prendre le temps
pour les nouveaux mais même pour les
anciens quand on fait évoluer les scènes
d'arrêter la vente sont d'arrêter sur
scène on prend le temps et je me déplace
pour qu'on puisse comprendre que la
tension on cherche à transmettre aux
spectateurs
c'est ça qui peut prendre solta
bourgeois barbares musiciens paysans roi
et noble gens de cour et de rue mais
aussi des cavaliers chevauchant une
vingtaine de peintures qui seront
présents presque à chaque tableau entre
combat équestre postillons autres
attelages de chars et de charrue zoo et
chabanel et responsable de la cavale
on essaye d'en mettre des scènes
équestres le plus possible après
c'est compliqué d'en mettre partout mais
on ya beaucoup de scènes du spectacle et
des chevaux pour monter des scènes
spécifiques pour une cascade ont fait
une traînée d'un moment aussi donc on
travaille avec des gens extérieurs mais
c'est beaucoup nous avec des compétences
en interne
que ce soit en combattant en cavalerie
on essaye de mélanger tout ça on fait
des stages l'hiver on fait des journées
des dimanches où on travaille ensemble
on essaye des cavaliers on essaye des
shows en voici avec les combattants ça
passe ou pas et on voit là on essaye de
voir s'ils échouent ils aiment ce qu'ils
font
les cavaliers pareil après on
sélectionne un peu des binômes pour
faire telle ou telle scène
[Musique]